The New Year begins
with millions of Catholics
around the world
offering up prayers and mourning
for the loss of Pope
Emeritus Benedict,
who died Saturday at the age of 95.
His body is lying in state
at St Peter's Basilica,
where public viewing begins Monday.
Earlier today,
Pope Francis presided over mass
in Vatican City,
sending prayers for his predecessor.
Now let's go to CNN's
Frederik Pleitgen
live in Saint Peter's Square.
Now the former pope left
a final letter published after his death,
and in it he asked for forgiveness
from those who thought he had,
quote, wronged
What can you tell us about this
letter and its meaning
Hi there, Paula.
Well, it was a pretty lengthy letter
that he left behind to
to those in the Catholic Church,
that which he oversaw.
But then also,
of course, to the many other people
that he dealt with
throughout his life as well.
And that letter touches on many subjects
it touches on.
You know,
when he was born, him
thanking his parents, thanking
the Catholic Church,
also his new home
as he put it here in Rome,
but also Bavaria, which is, of course,
where he comes from as well.
But it was quite interesting.
And that was also that segment
that we took a lot of note of as well,
where he asked for forgiveness
for those that he had wronged,
as he put it.
And I want to read to you that passage
real quick, just so our viewers can hear.
He said, quote,
To all those
I have wronged in any way,
I sincerely ask for forgiveness.
But I said before to my compatriots,
I now say to all those in the Catholic
Catholic Church
who have been entrusted to my service,
remain firm in the faith.
Don't get confused.
So obviously,
despite that,
there may be people that he had wronged.
He's asked for people
to to keep the faith
and to remain loyal
to the Catholic Church.
Of course,
one of the things
that we had been talking about
over the years reporting
when Pope Benedict was still in office,
was the fact that the Catholic Church
was dealing
with those sex abuse
scandals and generally abuse scandals
in that time.
And many felt
that Pope Benedict
wasn't taking the action
that many felt that he should have.
And in fact,
in the final months of his life,
he acknowledged that
he had made mistakes in the past.
This was pertaining to the time before
he was pope,
when he was the archbishop of Munich.
In the late
1970s
and early 1980s, acknowledging
that mistakes had taken place
there as well.
So this could pertain to that,
it could pertain to a lot of other things
as well.
One of the other things
that we also picked up on that letter
was way at the end
where he said
that despite the fact
that he had many flaws
about him, that he had committed sins,
that he asked
humbly asked, as he put it,
to be taken into God's heaven.
Nevertheless,
so those were the final words really
in that letter left that he left behind.
And something
of course,
that was very important here
in Rome, in the Vatican as well, Paula.
And I want to go back
to one of the moments
that really the
significant moment of his tenure.
He shocked the world's
1.2 billion Catholics by announcing
he was going to resign.
How consequential
was that decision at the time?
Well, I think it was I
think it was something
that was hugely consequential
because it was something
where he was the first pope to resign.
And I think it was around 600 years.
It was simply something
that was unheard of.
But at the same time,
I think
many people also felt
that it was quite a strong step
because he was acknowledging
that he was not up to the task
of running the gigantic organization.
And, you know, Paula,
I was actually here in Saint Peter's
Square when he became pope.
I saw him here on that balcony
when he took the reins
of the Catholic Church.
He was already 78 years old at that time
and had already been
a hugely influential
cardinal here
in the Catholic Church
for decades
before that, since the early 1980s,
there's a lot of people who say
that he was one of the most influential
people really in
a long time in the Catholic Church
and really ran the place
really the second one behind
Pope John Paul, the second at that time.
But he was already 78 years old
when he took the reins
of the Catholic Church.
And for the first couple of years
when he was pope
he did exude a lot of energy.
I remember the World Youth Day in Cologne
in 2005
where hundreds of thousands of people
showed up.
But you did notice that as time went on
some of these scandals came to light.
There were a lot of issues
in the Catholic Church
that he simply lost a lot of that energy.
He felt he was not up to it anymore.
And I think a lot of people believe
that it was a pretty strong
step on his part
to then acknowledge
that he was not up to the task
of running this gigantic organization,
which also needed some fresh leadership
at the top.
At that point, many people felt as well.